[Music]
is very easy to do it incorrectly and to
be satisfied incredibly that's what it
makes it difficult okay so on the first
thing lose the twelve to six
consciousness so he's at twelve by my
six and I goes as well this is incorrect
watch how it at the beginning these
already go around so my first step is
actually not to slow the you bring them
into the technique and you're already
injuring the runners so in some ways
your first step is oriented to the
ninety degrees that's where the Kazushi
is and that's where you make the first
communion if he's going to six if I go
to twelve there's no communion and it'll
manifest in your grip so go go like this
you see he's going that way you're
pulling this way
that's young too young that's not Aikido
so circle night version
[Music]
so watch then boom and I enter in here
and I pushing his energy flow not making
it go backwards nor does he as we can
when he feels the backwards hug Maori
eight himself this way slightly to my
technique that's just
so I generate this energy by redirecting
forward so we'll leave the Kazushi out I
don't care how you how you're doing is
what you're going to not pull him
backwards started moving around you
think
absorption and complete the cycle not
here spider-girl
okay this or now as the same thing
doesn't go here and stay there it
continues to spiral so I get you all the
way we started a circle and then that's
where I enter and now it's not that
acute an angle to reverse you okay one
I'm already starting to turn you do you
understand the angles already starting
to turn so when you have this arm I turn
it don't go for that whoa keep it
turning turn it that's right into now
this is a very broad angle absorption
complete the cycle in turn
[Music]
absorption complete the cycle I sure as
your IQ gets better right you have four
she's leaning on you right and then you
have the friction so you have to know
you can't override that friction do you
think you have to have the sensitivity
where I gotta get her leaning on me and
I'm using the friction she's not just
running over there do you understand
so I can't push it and I can't be off of
it nor can I have hey okay wherever my
hand goes you follow me no no no ideas
is right here I I'm controlling that
with how much friction might you circle
complete the cycle so if you take this
arm off and you go to here you're not
doing it home complete the cycle that
little step that's all I need
try to get wait so hey this step this is
the part I'm talking about but let's
let's look at it tactically you're just
trying to get to the back you understand
sir
she goes to fight me I'm just doing this
so we'll pull my infantry to that so you
can't step you go well that's her back
you can't step there because the
situation is dynamic now that steps
going to make your hands young because
you're moving away from her and you're
going to have to pull her so to stop
doing on keto and just do relationship
make sure that you're trying to get in
the back did you have this concept and
not wind up and throw relationship boom
boom boom dancing dancing dancing
dancing good health or pucker boom 10 is
about stay in the back behind her
weapons don't let her turn to face you
[Music]
always back here
okay try it
hi so you have you have to free your
mind so the farm has got you captured
you're going Edie me and you what comes
out to redeem e10 econ right you're like
this someone go like this and you lose
your stuff you're not free then the
principal is back
you will take whatever footwork get you
there without violating another
principle so this would violate a
principle this would violate a principle
okay so pay attention I'm Joo Dee Dee me
what do you want to call that stick
together be together because if I did
the other one I'm moving off to the side
you see not I think then I drop and I
have to lower with her because now I'm
losing connection so I take the other
foot I didn't move and I lower whisper
go back if I stay facing the sample and
she drops there she's not Vietnam aside
of me so watch how I move to stay in her
back always in the back
[Music]
or I'm always looking with my hips where
she is
don't let them get towards you in front
or you're over here and there on the
side you see she's sideways my hips are
here turn your body get ready to go to
the background
here
not here
you're in you're in a stance that's
mobile right so not on the ground not
back foot on the ground not head down
mobile so the backward is lightweight up
and the front foot is lightly out if
it's in your now sideways hips we're
okay let's go alright that is the easy
part and that's not the technique but if
you can't get there you likely can't do
the necessary part which is the internal
part so right now up to this point we're
just externally working on the outside
architecture but that generates the
incorrect Kazushi angle where she's kind
of tilting you see that you don't want
that you can't break people's balance
like that
so my what I'm doing is I'm getting her
turning right and as she comes around to
regain her balance I compress that you
see this
[Music]
so I'm not going here and then I dropped
me in her head and she goes like that
she she's trying to turn towards me
that's when I start compressing that
spine and that is nothing more Kiger can
keep your connection right boom that's
nothing more than a normal projection
I'm just aiming with it like that at any
mold and you can spike it right this
tilting is just all because you can it
becomes a gymnast for me instead I'm
here woman I compressed her spine okay
then she gets up and rather than coming
here which you can you just blended with
her scent
[Music]
so what everything is the same but the
internal is different whoa compressed
follow her down she gets up you control
the effect
everything is the same like we're not
tilting we're going right to his center
[Music]
same rules apply
do whatever flip maneuvers keep you in
the back as he's going to get up right
boom which I knew I moved because how he
got up he was coming around me hi so
he's down I move he gets up just don't
violate other principle
won't attack you senator so it's
position always prioritized position
this is where you want to be no bar to
do easily not you you want to be here
and the opening for a TV not yet
presented itself you don't want to do TV
now is you're going to come to the side
and you're going to do this big
clothesline scrap so I just look at me
at how I'm trying to stay on the back
she gets up on the back every time on
the back I'm still in back to her time
do you see I'm not on the side of her so
as as we go to fight if she does
whatever I'm still here I don't go I'm
not gonna go do TV not getting all right
you see I'm on this side right and she
gets up oh I'm ready
oh no every demon are you back
back comes in back back back back back
with that in mind as she gets up I'm
just leading her
[Music]
just like if she's pushing here right I
don't leave that hand
[Music]
if you panic and you hold her down and
she tries to get up
that's not Aikido or you pick her up and
you go like just stay a little ahead of
her
with Ikey you're using the same friction
that you used here you're use here
[Music]
so this this IP right here on her face
the one I'm demonstrating by keeping I
don't need to keep it that long I just
need to keep it for the EDB arm to get
back to its beginning of its cycle so
she goes disarms not ready DC battery so
that's it I got her this is it so I'm
not pulling right into there she's
getting up and that's it so you're now
obeying the rule I'm aiming a following
person
hey I'm not throwing her down so boom in
five compressions stay in the back
absorb that's it done I am NOT pulling
her compression die pull that's it done
more spine compression or spine
compression on acquisition to more less
let's go max for the Ikey oh no no no
you got on this side right here try it
again
stay in the back